this video was made possible by better
help.com / Pakman where you can get
affordable online access to a licensed
therapist through text phone and video
chat just click the link under this
video
welcome back to the David Pakman show of
course I'm not David I'm Benjamin Dixon
hosted the Benjamin Dixon show you can
check out my podcast anywhere you get
podcast or you could just subscribe to
my youtube channel where I post
occasional videos about politics and
where you will not get conspiracy
theories I am allergic to conspiracy
theories and that means something today
because on yesterday a conservative
leaning outlet The Washington Times
published a apology a retraction in
addition to an apology
for the conspiracy theory that they
spread about Seth rich and I this is
critical because this Seth rich has been
one of the stories that has beleaguered
the entire the entirety of the 2016
election and the Reid litigation of the
2016 election it's something that has
been pushed by the hard right by I mean
the the most deplorable of the
deplorable zhh as well as some in
progressive circles to be honest with
you there are a lot of people who push
this this this conspiracy theory and it
has become a so entrenched in our in our
discourse so believed because of
reputable outlets particularly
progressive outlets that peddled this
conspiracy theory that it has become a
statement of absolute faith that Seth
rich was assassinated by the DNC with
some connection to Hillary Clinton now
that language came from the right it
also came from an assertion made by
WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange which
will play that clip just to remind you
but it's it's one that has permeated has
I mean been instilled in almost like
indoctrination in progressive circles
some of the more uninformed portions of
progressivism but let me get to the
story here's a quote from actually I'm
the the article was short so I'm gonna
read the entire article because they
give you specifics and the specifics
really matter here and so this is from
this is the retraction from the
Washington Times they said quote the
Washington Times published an op-ed
column titled more cover-up questions
the curious murder of Seth rich poses
questions that just won't stay under the
official rug by Adam James Lyons who's
retired who the column on March 1st
online and on the March 2nd in it's
paper editions the column included
statements about Aaron rich the brother
of former Democratic National Committee
staff for Seth which that we now know to
be false one such statement was that
interesting and this is a quote from
their original article they said quote
interestingly it is well known in the
intelligence circles that in the
intelligence circles that Seth rich and
his brother Aaron rich downloaded the
DNC emails and was paid by WikiLeaks for
that information The Washington Times
noun does not have any basis watch this
does not have any basis to believe any
part of that statement to be true and
the Washington Times retracts it in its
entirety pause let's let's talk about
let's talk about this this sentence
right here time The Washington Times now
does not have any basis to believe any
part of that statement to be true what
happened now as opposed to when you
published it right what part of your
source is like you know either you
either it was not true then or you have
found that one of your quote unquote
sources was absolutely lying to you
which I think an outlet like this maybe
they would not have outed the source but
they would have said they would have
weasel their way out of this by saying
that according to one of our so
we trusted and we don't trust that
source anymore and so you know that that
type of thing there they aren't doing
this why should the Washington Times is
basically a rag and in many ways it's
it's a reasonable conclusion that they
didn't have any evidence then they
didn't have any evidence then to support
this or they just did extremely sloppy
journalism if you even want to call it
journalism or it's both but let's
continue reading there at least they at
least they've retracted and let's
continue reading the column also stated
quote also why hasn't Aaron rich been
interviewed by law enforcement and where
is he the Washington Times understands
that law enforcement officials have
interviewed mr. rich and that he has
cooperated with their investigation
The Washington Times did not intend to
imply that mr. rich had obstructed has
obstructed justice in any way and the
Washington Times retracts and disavows
any such implication I mean honestly you
could not have picked Duke
you could argue see if you're going to
try to do investigative journalism do it
and do it right because this tells me
that you didn't even really try it you
could not fight you found out now
probably through some type of lawsuit
but you didn't do your due diligence and
you made an accusation based on what
which is probably why it led to a
lawsuit which this article really smells
as though it's a part of a lawsuit
that's just conjecture but you know I
think it's a pretty safe conclusion at
this point last but not least the last
paragraph the Washington Times
apologizes to mr. rich and his family
all online copies of column have been
deleted and all online content
referencing the column has been deleted
to the extent within the Washington
Times Times as control the Seth rich
again to go back to what I was saying at
the beginning to set the rich
controversy conspiracy theory to be sure
has been one of the most discussed
after effects of the mm lingering
effects of the 2016 election because it
keeps coming back it's it and it is I
want you to Google a couple of things go
to YouTube actually and just Google Seth
rich and look at you know if you enjoy
making yourself angry so probably
shouldn't do this but just if you're
curious if you're curious go to a
comment section about Seth Ridge and
look at the derangement that is going on
and then keep reading and you realize
that this derangement isn't just coming
from Republicans this derangement is
coming from a lot of people in the
progressive circles and you don't have
to take my word for it because they're
written in hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of comments with thousands and
500 thousands of likes 500 likes the 200
likes all you know in every there it's
there to show you that this conspiracy
theory that was driven by so many people
on the right was also driven by some
voices on the left and it has purvey it
has it has become a pervasive problem
that even with this retraction this is
the biggest point even with this
retraction from a conservative media
outlet you're still going to have of
course some deplorable --zz believe it
but the sad the saddest thing is that
you're gonna still have progressives
don't believe this i want to play this
clip and we'll end with this this is
this is julian assange you know i I
don't really I have a lot to say about
Julian Assange but not in this segment
so I'm trying to I'm stammering because
I want to say some things but I won't
but just take a look at this this is
from I believe it's around 2015 to 2016
and this is what he had to say
insinuating that Seth rich was his
whistleblower and that he paid the
ultimate price whistleblowers go to
significant efforts to get us material
and often very significant risks as a 27
year old I works for the DNC who was
shot in the back murdered just two weeks
from unknown reasons as he was walking
down the street in Washington so that
was just a rubbery I believe wasn't it
no that's there's no finding so what is
distorting what are you suggesting I'm
suggesting that our sources take risks
and they are they become concerned to
see things occurring like that but was
he one of your sources then I mean we
don't comment on who our sources I make
the suggestion and here's the problem
Julian Assange lent his entire
credibility to fueling this conspiracy
theory and because so many people on the
Left respected and trusted Julian
Assange they held on to this and they
never let it go and matter of fact now
they still won't let it go because it is
it has become a part of the way of
thinking of a certain segment of the
left as well as an entire swath of the
deplorable right